Well, if you have facts and figures that you have to present,...
...look at what is really, really important within those facts and figures.
Figure out: "Well, why should people listen to what I have to say here?"
And only choose the things that are really important.
The rest of the information,...
...the audience can simply just look at it and pretty much understand it.
But what they don't know is the why or how behind those facts and figures.
So what you have to do then is choose the most important thing...
...or the main point from that particular slide...
...and talk about the why and how from that particular item,...
...and give a little background story and information about that.
That will make that information much more interesting and relevant to your audience.
That's how you can make facts or figures that may be boring...
...into something a lot more interesting for your audience.